[Musik]
schnur schnauz blütenreigen runde wo
vogelparadies was ist marco lorey
herzlich kommen wieder leute ich habe
heute max an meiner seite denn ich habe
mir letzte gericht einen sport wieder
mehr videos mit max zusammen zu machen
mag es hier mein kleiner bruder wie
einige von euch wissen und zu diesem
zwecke habe ich mir heute ein video
rausgesucht auf das ich schon mal da
geht doch zumindest auf dem kleinen teil
und zwar auf das video witzige wir haben
auch 70er und 80er jahren dazukommen wie
gesagt schon mal wieder von karten land
vor zwei monaten oder so da habe ich die
ersten drei oder vier minuten aus diesem
werbungs compilations video angeschaut
heute werden uns weiter zusammen den
rest des videos anschauen und werden
zusammen alte werbung rosten und belegen
jetzt los okay jetzt glaub ich bin mega
gespannt ich habe ein video dazu nicht
gesehen das heißt ich habe noch gar
keine von diesen komischen werbung
gesehen
wer das wirklich brauchst du wirklich
bist zigaretten liegt für gefehlt habe
ich auch sie kauft aber irgendwo eine
party ein lange der desktop ist also
zehn sekunden
wir sind noch nicht an dem punkt
angekommen damals werbezeit dem
fernseher war günstiger sollte aber auch
wie sie sagt dafür hab ich fast sie wohl
versuchen moment mal da gibt es doch die
mit den fünf sorten in einer packung
da ist sicher für jeden was dabei
[Musik]
snoop integrierte ja ganz gut das
produkt im wege
alter ist ja nicht die allerbeste
schokolade der ganzen welt weiß gerade
nicht wer das ist aber ich glaube die
bezahlen ja auch dafür dass das
widerspricht mehr alle in einer fünf
kostbare schokoladenspezialitäten in
einer packung 16 riegel einzeln verpackt
selber vor
er soll damals und die übelste neuerung
ist und verschiedene schokolade nach
einer packung hat ganz einfach so
mein gott das ist sogar davor kann man
keine dicke was mehrere
geschmacksrichtungen in einem produkt
anzupacken
das ist okay also kann immer daran
spannend
jetzt gibt es turner ist dass wir jetzt
ganz anders
okay es ist die flasche mit dem pollen
dreht ja
ja das hast du gerade eben schon gesagt
wir wissen dass es um den frisch prüfer
war geht ok
[Musik]
wo kann ich bestellen also alle leute
diesem raum sind so halb vergriffen ist
vom thompson korrekte aussage ja gut zu
wissen auch gern aber so die erklärung
also sprühten nicht nur an die wand
sondern du kannst tatsächlich auch das
ding gleich drehen und nach oben
springen
bei allen anderen vergleichbaren
produkten war es bisher so man konnte
das nicht so neigen herunterspielen aber
die haben es geschafft jedes wetter
schadet ihr friseur
deshalb gibt es von schwarzkopf das
besondere haarspray drei wetter taft
okay kann ich mal bitte irgendwie so
einen sonnigen tag genießen ne nein
auch sonst hat das schadet der frisur
drei wetter taft schütz bei feuchtem
wetter die frisur bleibt länger locker
und luftig
die für super duftig länger sogar hallo
erstmal die deutlich mehr durfte alter
hast du nicht von drei wetter taft
gehört ich meine es aber wirklich ein
problem ich bin letztes ziemlich im
körper angekommen der türsteher man so
ok braut sowie klar geht gar nicht
das haben hat geschmeidig die haltefrist
der deutsch du bei so einem wetter das
regenwetter das heißt gut und der wind
wehte die besucher bleibt die suche und
bei wind und wetter
was kommt als nächstes der jeder kennt
den ausdruck wind wird
achtung achtung heute ist wind wetter
achtung naja die fusion bleibt frisur
als ich dann verwandelt sich nicht etwas
grundlegend anderes okay also nicht in
gloucester nach canon stinktier auf den
kopf oder china es gibt ein foul
[Musik]
warum
das war so laut sein aber was war das
für ein actionfilm das lipperland das
ist neu sein okay okay ist ich bin zwar
mann und braucht das nicht aber die
kaufkraft der es ist alles neu
sicherheit und frische für jeden tag
viele slipeinlagen
der neue etat die wäsche schutz für
jeden tag gibt ihnen sicherheit und
frische zu jeder zeit waren noch mal
dran war das nochmal was in so einem
bestimmten zeitfenster ich weiß es nicht
ich gesagt habe war das für jeden tag zu
jeder zeit jeder stunde zu jedem moment
ich glaube es immer nachmittags um noch
mal hinhören schutz für jeden tag den
sicherheit und frische zu jeder zeit
also nicht nur jeden tag auch jederzeit
hier
das heißt auch wenn das mal kein tag ist
aber zeit aber dann ging es mit einlagen
sind selbst haften
leicht anschmiegsam und weiche packen
die stimme ist so unangenehm ist es soll
direkt in deinem alter so groß so
mussten wir immer ein ohr ein krippen
und sie hatten zeit und frische duft
[Musik]
unsere welt unsere zeit
worum geht's klick unsere weit unter
unserem neuen tweet wir deutsche in den
augen der franken war mieter dieses
gewollte erst dann gibt es an der
ostfront
ich habe ich hätte mir so unsere welt
unsere zeit war in der folge dessen die
70er und 80er in deutschland richtig
strom oder krank womit so krank
gerolltem r
so leute die zeit in der das in wald ist
es 40 jahre her und marco lohr schnurren
schnauz blütenreigen runde wo vogel
was ist das nur schnauze ist das
laufende film bewerben
was ist nano cola
mein hobby so bot dafür warum weil eine
mentale damals also meiner weser cool
das ist ein hobby ist wieso machst du
deine scheiss werbung dafür ein scheiß
hobby alter und außerdem ist es auch
schlecht erklärung für alle anderen
werden hobby es nicht ist und was ist
das denn was ist mama ich glaube du
konntest damals nicht immer mitspielt
wenn du einfach nicht voll auf
drogenfahrt übt er fragt was es nach
klose dessen augen so auf halb acht ist
auch computer nehmen was ist nano cola
erst leim auf inseln dann name kohle auf
streuen bilder aus geriebenem marmor auf
echtholz unter dem thema war scheiße
farbe also farbe ist ja wohl viel besser
als günstiger und geriet marmor mit
einem juni einsetzt schaffen sie es
brennt vor der stimmen junger was ist
los mit dir sein mini einsetzt schaffen
sie es nennt chor der stimmen
spielend geschafft was hat er geschafft
sein haus oder das eigene auf das haus
geschafft ja weil die frau jetzt ist
geschafft oder das gartentor mit kleinen
einsätzen und insignia einsetzt
die sich freute dass zu sagen ja was hat
er denn jetzt endlich geschafft mit
diesem einsatz ich will ich wissen wie
klein der einsatz ist ich will wissen
was und wie es geschafft hat wie gesagt
spielend geschafft nur ein kleiner kurze
frage der stelle waren alle leute damals
geistig aufnahme behinderten sowie aber
es ist also ich meine man sagt ja unsere
generation nach hause dass wir so eine
kurze aufmerksamkeitsspanne haben und
das stimmt auch aber ich hoffe dass das
hat aber unsere eltern sich angehört und
die leute damals werbung gemacht haben
sich gesagt okay ist
die sind so hängen geblieben müssen sie
wirklich acht mal sagen aber er hat auch
die münze und muss immer das gleiche
sagen wir können jedes andere zu sehen
diese münze liegt noch irgendwo rum und
immer wird diesen so eine schublade hat
man diese auch so toto lotto toto nein
nein das was von diesem video leute max
und einer beschreibung von den hier gibt
es einfach fotos nutzen können kamen das
war so weit von uns macht's gut